one of the things that I love hearing
about that I don't think we hear about
often enough is when you form that
really special bond mentorship
friendship on set I was reading in the
notes that you guys had that so it was
wandering but when did you realize oh
this is something special and what are
you gonna take with you from the
experience of working with each other
I'm gonna take her home from this
experience
I don't see my leg without care I feel
really lucky to have not just a coda but
every everybody on set no especially
Dakota but also everyone was super
supportive and and this is my second
movie coming out so it's been quite a
wild ride with such a cast and I'm just
so glad everyone was nice so glad
definitely one heck of a group to have
on your exacting feature so second
feature for you many many features for
both of you I was curious if you could
feel the difference that this is a
passion project for drew because it's
something that I was definitely able to
see and feel while watching it so how is
it working with a director that is just
so invested in making something like
this happen it's the best I mean when
you've got somebody that's that's
running that you know that's that's
running the show that has has such a
complete vision that's mapped out in
their brain it's and it's again it's not
based on some other piece of material
it's not based on the amusement park
ride or a board game or something it's
but it's just Drew's thing that the
story he wanted to tell and he sought it
out and he worked it out and he and he
did it and it's it's really quite
remarkable and it's you definitely feel
like hearing good hands in your be taken
care of like by somebody like that it's
so precise and a hundred percent a lot
of the times when I watch a movie with a
whole lot of mystery and I don't have
everything explained to me at the end
I'm like well why didn't I get that
information but here I found it really
satisfying what she gives you and what
he holds back but curious for you guys
just for getting into these characters
are there any specific details that
weren't on the script that you had to go
and ask drew just so you can really have
you know a fully realized version of
this character in your head
I thought our background was super
interesting and and it talks about our
our father a little bit and and what
that was and what that meant for us
didn't really show up we didn't talk
about it at all just little flashbacks
but hopefully it came through but that
was something that we had a couple of
conversations about I'm very that's a
big part of what the fun of the movie is
is that it's not completely spelled out
for you we just you realize that many of
these characters have secondary
existences or secrets or lies or lives
or whatever and you don't know them
specifically and it's left to you to
kind of go like oh that must be okay I
think I know what that's about that I'm
not sure and that's unsettling and the
film is meant to be unsettling question
here if you guys have the opportunity to
swap roles with anybody in this ensemble
who would it be and why just curse them
to it because of that ABS it's it's very
reasonable and earlier and he was eating
skittles on some skittles and abs just
was my eighties hot band that I was in
so good